on a fait plein de super jeu ce soir
mais il nous en reste un
appel c'est maman qui choisit lequel de
vous survivra à la furent jamais c'est
l'âme de notre pays qui est en jeu
la purge vise les pauvres et les
innocents sénatrice pas gagné et atteint
chargé des tas de choses
il est grand temps de s'occuper de cette
sénatrice la purge doit être supprimée
sans attendre vous prenez le gros risque
que madame la sénatrice il le faut
les seuls de ma famille à avoir survécu
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à bout par
ce poste j'ai failli faire quelque chose
pendant la purge chez quelques années je
veux que ça s'arrête
je veux des hommes dans toutes les
pièces tout est sous surveillance vidéo
c'est parti ceci n'est pas un exercice
ce message d' alerte annonce le
commencement de la purge annuelle dès
que retentira la sirène tout crime y
compris celui d'homicides sera légale
durant les douze heures qui suivront
votre gouvernement vous remercie de
votre participation
on nous a trahis
c'est pas un exercice
on est seul
on n'a pris qu'un but maintenant
survivre
madame suivez nos vous comprenez ce qui
est en jeu ici
côté face j'ai le progrès les voilà
oui
béni soit l'amérique qui nous laisse
purger et purifier nos âmes
joignez vous à moi et tyrannique ont le
mal
plus fort
purgeant même plus
ou des bienfaits de la période